film courage women
and caring
there's this pattern that I've noticed
from all the people that have come out
here mark and I are both from Florida
and what that meant for me I'm I was
naive to what Hollywood wasn't was going
to be I thought that you made a short
film you'd come out here and they just
be standing on the side of the road
handing out three-picture deals and that
is not the case apparently I wasn't this
tony west right there look scrabble you
know look you know the brochure lied to
come out here so then you get here and
then a lot of people myself included you
sort of get into this funk when you
realize that it's not going to happen
and what happened for me if i was
talking about the perception successes i
wasn't doing anything i was waiting
around I was waiting for some magical
phone ring or somebody to meet someone
who was like I'm looking for a protégé
I'll be your mentor and change your life
and that doesn't happen all the time
that's not the way it happened so when
we got together he's absolutely right
the thing we started doing was not
waiting for permission we just started
doing and I am I mean I'm human you know
I definitely have insecurities you know
one of the things that I was just
talking to chris rice about the other
day as my little brother just bought a
home you know in orlando florida okay in
a really great neighborhood and he's
married and he's on the the typical like
um business path you know a corporate
business path and he's doing great for
himself and I in and it makes you think
you know like what am i doing you know
if those questions like creep in once in
a while but at the same time you know
like I I I know that I'm doing what I
love to do and I know that I'm doing
what I want to do and take me a little
bit longer to get a house than my little
brother that's fine